ya es ley el matrimonio igualitario es
realidad en chile tras la firma del
presidente sebastián piñera todas las
parejas que así lo desee independiente
su orientación sexual podrán vivir el
amor contraer matrimonio y formar
familia con toda la dignidad y
protección legal que sin duda necesita
el primer es el proyecto llevaba más de
cuatro años en discusión bajo la
oposición de los diputados más
conservadores incluida en un principio
la del presidente saliente quien varió
su postura para anunciar en junio que
había llegado el tiempo para aprobar
esta norma este jueves la comunidad lgtb
y chilena celebra una medida que los
equipara en derechos al resto de la
ciudadanía siempre entendimos que en
algún tema no era un tema valórico sino
un tema de igualdad de derechos porque
el estado chileno no es considerada de
segunda clase porque el estado chileno
nos considera a nuestros hijos de
segunda categoría así que hoy día es un
día muy importante para nosotros porque
finalmente se aprobó el matrimonio
igualitario desde el año 2015 las
personas homosexuales podían unirse bajo
la figura legal del acuerdo de unión
civil
nueva ley junto al matrimonio se
garantiza también el reconocimiento
legal de los hijos en común con esta ley
estamos agradecido pero enormemente
felices por fin ahora vamos a poder ir
al registro civil y quien es certificado
de nacimiento aparezcamos a ambas como
su madre un gran día para la comunidad y
las plataformas lfc que fueron señaladas
por piñera como el principal motor de
esta nueva ampliación de derechos en
chile- el matrimonio igualitario fue uno
de los temas que marcó la campaña
presidencial del país que tuvo su
primera vuelta al 21 de noviembre y se
definirá el próximo domingo en segunda
vuelta en ella se enfrentarán el
izquierdista gabriel boric y el
ultraderechista josé antonio kast que
defiende el matrimonio como una unión
exclusiva entre un hombre y una mujer